[Musique]
montréal une ville et ses nombreux
scandales à son extrémité est
l'arrondissement pointe aux trembles
rivière des prairies un immense
territoire qui fait saliver les
promoteurs en fait l'arrondissement
c'est l'arrondissement du bout de l'île
dans l'est qui a encore le plus fort
potentiel de développement résidentiel
commercial et industriel
ce qu'un terrain vague et intérêts ou
lloris et est en friche
il faut construire de toutes pièces des
quartiers les condos ces deux à z
c'est un terreau extrêmement fertile
beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
un des plus gros projets résidentiels
des dernières années dans ce secteur et
le projet valencia sur le site marc
aurèle fortin
ce site a une dimension de 200 mille
mètres carrés ce qui équivaut à la
superficie de 27 terrains de soccer
des terrains ont été vendus au coût de
seulement un million et demi de dollars
en 2006 alors que la ville avait dépensé
beaucoup plus pour l'acquérir à la fin
des années 80 7 2 7 millions de dollars
que s'est il donc passé
après l'avoir payée par le remembrement
des différents lots on avait payé 7
millions 500 mille la valeur foncière
montea 10 millions puis finalement on
leur doit vendu un million cinq cent
mille
on a vraiment l'impression que on est on
a voulu contourner des règles des
règlements aujourd'hui une élue de l'est
de montréal décide de jouer cartes sur
table
ce n'est pas la première fois que la
mairesse chantal rouleau dénonce les
pratiques d'octroi de contrats ou de
terrains dans son arrondissement
l'automne dernier elle lançait un cri du
coeur pour que la police vienne enquêter
chez elle c'est intolérable
on peut plus continuer des fous il faut
que les citoyens se réveille s'il faut
aller dans la rue pour pour que ça cesse
ballon dans les rues pour que ça cesse
nous avons depuis mis la main sur un
document interne de l'arrondissement qui
soulèvent des questions dans ce document
on c'est un fonctionnaire qui affirme
anonymement le marché n'intervient pas
lorsque la ville de montréal mais un
terrain en vente à rivière des prairies
il ya seulement un petit groupe qui peut
se permettre de soumissionner ce
document fait longuement état du projet
marc aurèle fortin
pour la mairesse rouleau il s'agit d'un
autre exemple de transactions douteuses
il ya eu deux avis juridiques qui ont
été demandés tous ont un lien avec le
comité exécutif de la ville de montréal
et il ya eu avec les avis juridiques
on a écarté les les proposant et un
deuxième comité de sélection ont été
formés on a éliminé le premier on a
formé un nouveau comité de sélection et
ils ont appris le dernier proposant qui
lui a déposé une offre de 1 million
finalement c'est le consortium petra
saint luc qui a été retenue par le
deuxième comité de sélection
malgré que son offre était la plus basse
des trois soit un million de dollars
petra saint luc à plus tard égaler
l'offre d'iberville de 1,5 million de
dollars
mais on est quand même loin du pic à
payer la ville pour ce terrain 7,7
millions de dollars déjà le vérificateur
de la ville de montréal dans son rapport
de l'année 2009 s'était interrogée sur
le faible prix de vente de ce terrain il
écrivait nous travaux de vérification ne
nous ont pas démontré avec certitude que
le montant de mises à prix correspondait
à la valeur marchande du terrain
concerné
si le prix a été si basse et que
l'évaluation par la ville du coût des
infrastructures comme les rues les
trottoirs ou les égouts était très élevé
or ces coûts sont à la charge de
l'acheteur plus les infrastructures sont
chères - le terrain a de la valeur les
opérations de surveillance
aujourd'hui la mairesse rouleau
soupçonne que cette évaluation des coûts
auraient été gonflés considérablement
les prix d'évaluation qui a été soumis
semblerait beaucoup trop élevé la
mairesse n'est pas la seule à
s'interroger
selon nos sources le nouveau contrôleur
de la ville alain bande aurait les mêmes
soupçons qu'elle ce spécialiste des
questions municipal s'interroge aussi
une succession d'erreurs c'est toujours
possible
mettons que là on est et on le fait une
belle séquence mais le coût élevé des
infrastructures n'est pas le seul
élément qui cloche dans l'octroi du
terrain du projet marc aurèle fortin
toujours dans son rapport le
vérificateur de la ville
s'interrogeait sur le processus de
sélection ayant mené à la vente des
travaux la mairesse rouleau pense elle
qu'on a voulu favoriser indûment le
groupe petra saint-luc notamment dirigé
par giuseppe borsellino
alors que le groupe iberville est arrivé
premier
à l'époque on a expliqué que l'offre du
groupe iberville ne correspondait pas
aux exigences de la ville qui voulait
plus de maison témoin de condos mais la
mairesse rouleau n'en démord pas elle
croit que l'offre d'iberville était bien
supérieure à celle de pétra saint luc et
oui il était plus favorable montant
était plus élevé puis il y avait une
densité plus importante aussi il y
aurait eu plus de revenus en fait
je crois que n'importe quel autre projet
aurait eu plus d'impact positif que
celui là vraisemblablement on a tout
fait pour orienter une décision parce
que vous aviez jusqu'à dire qu'on a
voulu favoriser le groupe petra de
giuseppe borsellino joe borsellino
oui je crois qu'on a voulu favoriser les
groupes petrov
giuseppe borsellino et son groupe petra
est un des développeurs les plus
importants de la région de montréal il
n'hésite pas à s'afficher publiquement
avec le gratin politique lors notamment
d'activités de financement comme
celle-ci organisé en 2006 par tony
tomassi et où étaient présents le maire
d'arrondissement de l'époque
cosmo maciocia est le premier ministre
charest il est tellement influent au
sein de communautés italiennes qu'à
saint léonard on a installé un buste de
lui de sa femme au centre communautaire
léonard de vinci dans le rapport interne
de l'arrondissement rivière des prairies
que nous avons obtenu un fonctionnaire
témoigne anonymement en dix ans à
l'époque tout le monde à la ville
étaient intimidés par borsalino il était
perçu comme quelqu'un qu'il ne fallait
pas confrontés
c'est donc le consortium dont fait
partie petra qui appartient à giuseppe
borsellino qui a remporté la mise pour
le terrain marc aurèle fortin à rivière
des prairies à la même époque où se
déroulait l'appel d'offres borsellino
par l'entremise de sa compagnie petra
vendaient à un prix avantageux de
terrain à saint léonard aux deux enfants
du directeur général de l'arrondissement
de rivière des prairies
pierre santamaria terrains sur lesquels
ils se sont construit ses luxueuses
résidences
les deux ont vraisemblablement fait une
bonne affaire puisqu'ils ont obtenu un
rabais de presque 100 mille dollars
chacun sur l'évaluation municipale des
deux terrains nous avons joint pierre
santamaria qui n'a pas voulu nous donner
d'entrevue à la caméra c'est beaucoup
moins cher que le marché
c'est beaucoup moins cher que
l'évaluation pour les droits de mutation
vous voyez pas quelque chose de mal
là-dedans que deux enfants du dg de
l'arrondissement fasse affaire avec une
partie des voies étaient impliqués c'est
peut-être un peu rentrer ça comment dire
ça ne respecte pas les apparences de non
conflit d'intérêts est-ce-qu'il plus un
peu plus embêtant dans ce cas là c'est
le prix de la transaction
le puits de la transaction qui est
anormalement faible c'est assez
difficile de comprendre comment ce qu'on
peut arriver à réaliser une si bonne
affaire
ce n'est pas tout marisa la fille de
pierre santamaria qui a obtenu un dea de
terrain travaille pour le cabinet
d'avocats qui a émis une opinion
juridique ayant pour effet d'écarter la
candidature du groupe rival de pétra
saint-luc iberville au téléphone mme
harris a refusé de nous dire si elle a
participé à cet avis juridique
son patron lui défend l'impartialité des
avis l'ancien directeur général de
l'arrondissement
le père de marie saint pierre santa
maria prétend que tout a été fait dans
les règles de l'art avant l'ouverture
des enveloppes l'ouverture des
enveloppes scellées le 16 novembre 2005
et que la firme d'avocats qui a écarté
la candidature d'hébertville
c'est la firme d'avocats de votre pays
non vous étiez au courant des trains et
donc c'est qu'une coïncidence
regardez on est dans les mêmes dates
donc il ya un appel d'offres on nous a
dit que j'étais très actif pour que
petroplus obtenir le terrain je m'excuse
pour expliquer plus à nous aussi
pourtant dans l'appel public de
propositions de la ville de montréal on
indique bien que le comité de sélection
du projet marc aurèle fortin fera un
rapport au directeur de l'arrondissement
justement monsieur santamaria quoi qu'il
en soit la mairesse rouleau cv de
séparer de lui
une fois élu en 2010 monsieur
santamaria mais va faire soit de
poursuivre ou soin de prendre sa
retraite et puis nous avons convenu
qu'il prenait sa retraite parce que
c'est votre affaire à cliquer c'était
c'est tellement de choses donc pour
exiger qu'il a été démissionné d'une
certaine façon il a pris sa retraite
ça va faire
[Musique]
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là c'est une
compagnie à la mafia capte nu le contrat
de construction des infrastructures sur
le site marc aurèle fortin mirabeau
construction un de ses actionnaires de
munichois curie est décrit par la police
comme étant au centre de la
réorganisation de la mafia à montréal
mirabeau et partout dans l'est
la compagnie a effectué la majorité des
infrastructures des projets résidentiels
à rivière des prairies entre 2003 et
2009 sur le terrain voisin de
marc-aurèle-fortin mirabaud a fait les
rues et les trottoirs etc samara une
compagnie et lui dénier avec un autre
mafieux
raynald desjardins qui construit les
maisons ce dernier est accusé du meurtre
de salvatore montagna qui tentait de
remplacer vito rizzuto à la tête de la
mafia
selon nos informations dominique war
curie était très présent au conseil
d'arrondissement de rivière des prairies
art curie a même été reçu
accompagné par l'ancien conseiller
municipal de son secteur joe magri dans
les locaux de la ville centre pour
négocier une vente de terrains
curieusement personne ne semble avoir
fait affaire avec lui ni joe magri ni
l'ancien maire d'arrondissement cosmo
match crucial
ni sammy forcillo l'ancien responsable
des infrastructures à la ville de
montréal qui dit ne pas être au courant
non plus des allégations de gonflement
de coûts des infrastructures dans
marc-aurèle-fortin je vous dis monsieur
vous m'apprenez ces informations et foot
il faut garder les yeux monsieur les
jeunes de brax au froid l'actuelle
mairesse ne cache pas son inquiétude
devant cette situation de jeu concède
2003 2009 sauf erreur à peu près 3 que
les infrastructures à luire des prix
d'un secteur résidentiel ont été faites
par mirabaud construction à force de
fouiller et puis non on a bien vu l'a
écoutée de ça va faire bientôt deux ans
que je suis en poste
la mairie de l'arrondissement et
mirabaud mirabeau mirabeau oui c'est la
mafia
ça semble être ça se passe ailleurs à
montréal pas juste chez nous là et chez
nous c'est c'est bien c'est bien
particulier puis il ya des gens qui
réside chez nous et qui vient de
construire chez nous et quand on parle
entre autres de mirabeau ou le des
terrains où les infrastructures ont été
faites par mirabaud donc par dominique
war curie qui est lié à la mafia et où
les maisons étaient construites par sa
mère à où il ya un lien avec raynald
desjardins
il dit aussi avec la mafia donc c'est
pas un mythe chez vous la présence de
noms furent non ce n'est pas la santé
oui oui personne n'en parle mais oui on
laissait oui la mairesse rouleau ou ira
témoigner à la commission charbonneau
pour dire entre autres que rien n'a
changé dans son arrondissement
magri nouvelle loi et les nouvelles
règles et malgré la formation de
nouvelles escouades changer de mettre
fin à la corruption
depuis le début on se pose des questions
qui a fait quoi commun pourquoi plus
savoir plus plus ça s'éclaircit
mais il ya vraiment enquête à faire et
ce que ça démontre sur cs au score puis
en a d'autres il y en a un système qui
existe à montréal il ya des gens qui en
profite
sur le dos des contribuables il faut
mettre un terme à ce manque d'argent à
l'arrondissement
on est obligé de couper dans des
services aux citoyens dans
l'arrondissement au coupon run pour des
5000 et 10000 des 35000 dollars ca des
impacts importants pour le service aux
citoyens pendant qu'on fait cet exercice
là qui est difficile
on voit des comme un fleuve qui se
créent à côté où des gens en poche et
d'humains sur le dos des contribuables
et ça me choque
le contrôleur de la ville alain band a
remis son dossier à l'escouade marteau
de la sûreté du québec qui l'analyse
[Musique]
ton